next up the war on Santa if you're
watching the show with your kids you're
a great parent thank you and also sorry
for all the times I did this but before
this next piece here is a disclaimer
spoiler alert the following video
contains information pertaining to the
existence of Santa according to a new
study it's damaging for parents to lie
to kids about Santa Claus before Jesus's
birthday here's a fair and balanced take
from Fox News they suggest that lying to
children could undermine their trust in
parents as a result leaving them open to
abject disappointment if parents can lie
so convincingly and over such a long
time what else can they lie about first
of all you those kids this is all dumb
yeah I love this like oh don't lie to
your kids but go ahead and keep getting
your news from a totally biased news
I'm out coming out come in Sam you know
this wasn't very nice comedians at this
very sensitive time of year what else is
triggering you about Santa Claus Scott
Aukerman now I don't believe it when I
hear anyone is coming to town my uncle
Cavalia yeah none of them yeah I love
the 90s to Boyd's tell sequence I saw
Mommy Kissing him but he didn't have a
beard and he looked a lot like her
Pilates instructor all right boys I'm a
vegan but I reindeer meat out of spite
yes very good
good you showed up